now you may have seen the campaign it's
been online on the internet and
everything about
this had this hand gesture which is what
someone can do to silently tell you that
they're in trouble that they they need
some assistance
often related to domestic violence so if
you see that
you know you've got to act but what
about the people that you can
talk to you know when you finally sort
of get out the house and actually
talk to someone of course we all chat to
our hairdressers
don't we so are they the people that
actually
could be a lifeline for the people
affected by domestic violence there is a
new campaign called
cut it out it's looking at training the
hair and beauty industry to be more
receptive to the hidden troubles of
their clients urging them to report
violence
and seek help well let's talk to the
hairstylist nikki clarke
who's getting involved in this and
sergeant in the thames valley violence
reduction unit as well as creator of
this initiative
claire furness good to see you both this
morning claire
why did you think that hairdressers
actually were going to be
actually a good avenue for people to to
reach out and ask for some help
well i think having your hair done is a
real personal service
um and actually they're they're like
therapists so
we understand that it's quite
commonplace for people to make
disclosures about their relationships
and perhaps
the unhealthy nature of those
relationships so
with that in mind i think it's really
useful to to support the
professionals in that sense by providing
them with some guidance and training
around the subject of domestic abuse
yeah nikki i mean this
it it almost once it's presented it
seems like common sense doesn't it
because
well you know we we talk to you guys
about everything under the sun so
you know these sort of issues could come
up
absolutely i mean it's quite
extraordinary that you you say it is a
simple thing and it is
because you know people do confide in
their hairdressers i mean it's quite
extraordinary
i think it's because they feel quite
vulnerable with
um you know wet hair and possibly no
makeup
you know hairdressers have taken on the
place of
i mean i wouldn't necessarily say
therapist all the time
but certainly as a confidant and i think
that this
campaign is there to just try and be
able to direct hairdressers to spot the
signs
and you know and to be able to direct
them to the right people
that are going to be able to help but so
it's all about training nikki then
because you
you won't want to you know to put people
in the spotlight where they don't quite
know what to do or how to react so how
important is the training going to be
for
for you and your team for example
well the training is going to be
paramount i mean i'm on my way there
now to see um just in fact how this is
going to be done and how i can help
you know talk to my staff about it and
but also
really the whole of the industry really
needs to um
to be to just be made aware of it and it
may just be some
very very simple signs so you know i'm
going to learn a lot this morning
myself but as i say it was a very very
simple idea and of course
we're in a perfect position to be able
to help yeah so
in terms of the training then claire
what what are you putting forward is it
about being able to say the right thing
to those who are vulnerable or
or point them in the right direction or
to alert services like the police
yeah it's a combination of all of it
really it's spotting the signs and
symptoms of domestic abuse because of
course domestic abuse isn't just
physical abuse it's multifaceted there
are lots of um
things that happen in relationships and
it's pointing out those signs and
symptoms and then
being able to signpost those victims for
support for the local charities and also
those national charities as well
how happy happy is the wrong word
how how rewarding is it that you've got
people like nikki getting involved with
this which obviously gives the campaign
a huge lift and hopefully is going to
get people across the country
hairdressers and beauticians wanting to
get involved in this
absolutely i mean it's so fantastic that
nikki has backed this
it's really taken it to that next level
i mean my dream is for it to be mandated
in the qualifications so that every
student hairdresser that comes through
has to go through this process of
understanding those signs and symptoms
because
essentially we're creating an army of
eyes and ears within the community that
can support statutory agencies like
ourselves
and those um support charities um both
nationally and locally
would you like to see that nikki sort of
this is this built into the the
curriculum if you like
you know i don't think it's that
far-fetched actually i mean really we're
talking about people
just being aware and this is a national
problem and i think that
you know it's interesting what claire
said it's not always the physical signs
but it's that kind of mental abuse as
well and of course we're not just
talking about women here
you know we're talking about men as well
so i think it's a really
important aspect of what we do and yes i
do hope
it would be actually you know built in
yeah
claire can we talk about the male side
of this i mean i know
women are more victims i think it's one
in four women fall victim
to this in some way shape or form but
it's about one in six men as well which
is
still a significant number
absolutely yeah one in six men do suffer
uh domestic abuse but of course we know
that there are so many more hidden
victims
um within the male community out there
and so that's really important for our
barbers for example to get on board and
and do this training so that the
awareness is there
um so that they're able to safely
signpost these men to to services that
are available both locally and
nationally for them
and once people do reach out claire what
support is available
for them i mean because it's all about
being it's a very difficult step isn't
it to
to move away from an abusive
relationship
absolutely obviously we have the
statutory service us the police
that people can report to but also those
national agencies you've got
women's aid mankind they would offer
support and guidance around what to do
next those safe steps to take
there are a wealth of programs out there
as well to kind of re-educate yourself
on what a healthy relationship should
look like
which i would implore any victim to kind
of pursue really
it's refreshing nikki that i mean you
say you're off to do some training now
i always think it's really refreshing
when someone especially is established
as you turns around and says i'm going
to learn something new here i'm going to
make a difference
you know it's interesting um you know
it's something that
you know i do feel quite strongly about
i mean we hear about it on the news all
the time
and actually this was just an
opportunity for us to
to really do something about it and you
know we talked about building it into
the curriculum
you know these things should be part and
parcel of
how people behave in relationships and i
think
you know certainly in lockdown i think
we've all had time to
to think quite carefully and of course
we've seen an increase in that happen as
well so
the timing couldn't be more apt yeah
absolutely
nikki and claire really good to see you
both this morning thank you